Look out at the world.
Isn't it wonderful?
And see all the places we call home:...
...handbuilt hideaways,...
...castles in the clouds,...
...and bungalows with a beach out back.
On Airbnb.com, you can book and stay in any one you like,...
...all for a price that suits you.
It's simple.
Just enter where you want to go, the dates you want to be there,...
...and choose from thousands of places.
Then decide between a room or having the whole Airbnb home to yourself.
Before you travel, you can chat with your host, so you're not meeting a stranger.
And you can leave reviews for each other after your stay .
Make yourself at home, wherever you go, belong anywhere with Airbnb.